my presentation today I was intense to
discuss what we might face in the post
arbitration scenario in pain distrans
fallacy
thank you so I will start with very
briefly what we considered as the major
causes for the South China Sea disputes
I think fundamentally we have this
debating on the issue of legacy from the
Second World War and we heard yesterday
morning there isn't our audience phone
who is asking the Impala of san
francisco peace treaty I think that's
exactly the treaty that all these
climate states based their claims
sovereignty claim on for the vietnamese
perspective because this article 2 of
San Francisco treat actually put fly
category of sovereignties that Japan is
supposed to return to buy in article 2
of and without mentioning to which
country that the sparkly and parcel will
be returned to so Vietnamese based on
the French colony or unknown
demonstration and then I think for the
Philippines perspective is based on the
argument that I consider those sparkly
some parts partly as abandoned territory
and from Chinese perspective because it
neither I'll see or PRC were invited to
the San Francisco treaty but they do
there is a treaty be decide between
Japan and our see government in 1952
exactly the same day when the san
francisco peace treaty become effective
and then in that particular bilateral
treaty are they go to be and FB is
referring to taiwan and punku and to
alpha is referring to parasol and
spotless so that's how we consider that
food is bilateral treaty that Japan is
retaining those features to our see
government and certain we hear a lot of
your political or strategic factors
report that we heard from yesterday in
addition to many resources and certainly
on the law of the sea issues and here so
this diagram actually shows how all
these disputes categorized with center
we have this so many issue which is not
governed by the laws convention
and then about this island with dramatic
120 121 and also how much effect that
the middle is no tiny island of features
in the middle of the ocean might have
what kind of impact my heart for the
future the invitation those are the
issues that we are facing and so doing
what count baseline normal baseline or
straight base I even like about a
comparable baselines and certainly there
are the concept which is exactly what
the conflict or what the disputes
between China and other Clement states
about many color historic concept where
he is though right and he stormed what
it does not appear in any single
provisional of the convention except for
some mentioning in article 10 15 and 29
degree of nadie of history based on his
royal title and also we have this
territory issues and all this country
they always button into some passage
except for some countries they have up
to master regulations on worship
navigation on the easy regimes all these
countries they clip based there clamps
on the easy regime but they do we do
share I'll have a lot of maybe some
interpretation on the military activity
that Delta Corning explained yesterday
between US and China out for example we
are we regarded not every tire of
military activity will be considered as
read navigations and certainly they were
also very important part may of own
crore which talked about in the semi
semi or enclosed COSM incracy all the
states are required to take regional
cooperation when they exercise now right
on performing their duties but this
discussion on partner has been
overshadowed by the account set of
islands regime American teen mutation
and then we have this very important
part of important issue of part 15 about
the dispute settlement on their own
course it's a very comprehensive
American history of mechanism
and part 1 require all the stage go
choose for peaceful means to settle the
dispute and then part two when orders
they fail to reach consensus to real to
solve their problem than the required to
go to composite is resettlement
mechanisms and then but part 3 will
continue with there is a limitation and
exception for the compulsory disputes
and our life span of one minute to
explain what is mystery of article 298 I
thin the loves convention with so many
ratifying country's signature countries
actually come as a package deal that a
country in order to win something you
have to lose something I think to not
exactly we flood what has been the
outcome through the 30 years of
negotiation so basically it gives a
country a right to exclude certain types
of disputes including sovereignty issues
including maritime limitation military
activities and certain types of law
enforcement from a composite third party
form I think that explains why many
countries where they have concerns about
whether they want to go to a third-party
forum but because of our particular
article 298 leave a country room to
actually choose a way that it's prefer
so the idea of one to explain what is
China suppose to international law
because we really have a lot everyone's
calling to try calling China to add
according to international rules and
based rules based in managing the issues
in the South China Sea so let me explain
a little bit what is Chinese attitude or
approach to international law so that
will be a breaking down into two phrase
why is from nineteen forty nine to
nineteen seventy-eight so Chinese added
to you towards international law has
being barren two distinct features
critical rejection and also positive
construction so on the one hand China
was very critical of traditional
international law they understood to
primarily
protector in trees or colonial and
ahsoka imperious power and to the
determinant of most development state so
trying to consider you as a developing
States but on the other hand although
China was precluded from taking seats in
the United Nations backing up before
9070 and China especially indoors the
purpose in principle UN Charter and the
principle of sovereign equality peaceful
mutual respect well having said that I
think I I owed you explanation of what
Professor ter explained yesterday when
he said what China's four minutes make a
stem and China's bacon other countries
small and I think there is a background
on that sentence and dozens only holiday
original sentence you know when China
and have discussion either bilateral
original forum and it's we in together
with us in the States and China we are
describing like this we are actually
Asian family and then our neighbors come
estate well very funny discussion
Chinese big and you are just kinda like
a big brother in a family and we are
small were little brothers so in Asian
culture the big brother is supposed to
take care of the small brothers so I
think we're by the weight is not despair
was not by young one he was by young
jeezy if we are talking about 2010 so
his sentence and I actually had the
chance to talk to the people who are
involved in a meeting they said Young gh
is meaning we are well there's a fat
Chinese big in size and other countries
smoking inside this is a fairer we
cannot deny but being big meaning that
it doesn't mean necessarily that we have
to impose pressures to our small
neighbors and beans more it doesn't not
necessarily mean that you are weak and
this is the message implying that in
that statement and so I don't think it's
wise enough for a country's foreign
ministry to make that kind of silly
argument you know saying they were big
you're small that's why we have to I
think he's his messages because China
has been taking very careful of the
points of a sovereign equality I don't
think that's why I send out for him to
make that just a misinterpretation
and also once you speak a little
participation in own cross and China
only stopped into the negotiation on in
the middle of the whole negotiation
although he has many concerns about the
law of sea convention by signing the
logs combination might help some impact
for South China Sea claims but having a
journal cause and benefit analysis and
also back in that time I heard many
arguments some of the people who
attended negotiation does not know
enough knowledge about love singer
nervously convention anyway china has
been very actively participating in the
launch on cross process so it has also
jumped it or passed many domestic
legislation along with the lobster
cambridge including its 1992 territory
and Tico's own law and also night at a
easy and convenient law and in terms of
Mary legislation review we will look at
that and in a socially see we have a
bunch of areas that cover by the law of
C conversion we're talking about marine
pollution we're talking about search and
rescue you we're talking fishery
management and China has been signing
very I think every single multilateral
conventions in that regard and then in
terms of they are state parties of
dispute settlement because Chinese very
clear will China decide not to
participate in this arbitration case and
that's why the lot to a lot of
assumption everyone is saying or assume
that try not tryna does not prefer a
third-party compulsory dispute
settlement I think the we have to
understand this situation the South
China Sea if we take for instance WT or
negotiation it's very interesting lead
up to your process thought to be the
most important indicator for the foreign
scholars to study the changing role of
China in the international legal order
so if we look at the WTO they have also
helped this compulsory dispersal
mechanism Chinese for us being very
frequent using that mapping them to
celebrate straight issues so but when we
talk about the South China Sea we're
talking about sovereignty issues
maritime the limitations in a constant
obsession i see i think it's rational to
understand what countries has to take a
second thoughts in actual living the
issues most censorship for third party
to make a decision but having said that
i don't personally are for my own spirit
on my own perspective I don't appreciate
China's position not to participate in
front and very beginning as a studio
maintenance law and we always think that
when we use our knowledge about
international law and about these
magazines I'm speaking too long sorry i
hope i do some provocative so that is
the route so but i do i think i do want
to share with you although i don't buy
the position that trying to decide not
to participate but i think our i
understand why china did that so chinese
position on the arbitration case first
of all legally it's about the
jurisdiction em by the miscibility first
of all we believe that according to
Article 283 there's not enough exchange
between the two countries so we have not
exhausted the exchange of views what has
been discussing through the bilateral
china philippine Pellegrini causation
it's about sovereignty is about
mentality and meditation and we never
talk about how we're going to do with
individuals more individual features
whether it's an island to rock so at
least have never been discussed by the
two countries and also are eager to now
81 and 282 both country agreed to see
certain of dispute by peaceful means of
their own choice and i think for that
part in china related to a lot refer to
a lot of regional discussion and also do
see that all the country agreed to
settle that these two are managing the
issues by a peaceful means and certainly
I think Chinese argument is also based
in article 2 nite a although the 15
submission in the Philippines our
suitcase and trying to delink two issues
from sovereignty and marathon
delimitation by China firmly believe
without addressing the territory issues
and those submission in the Philippines
15 summation will not be able to our to
adjust and this is have plenty of
arguments on jurisdiction and
miscibility but unfortunately because of
government's decision not to participate
so kind of lost Charles to resent a
legal argument there and the second the
second reason why China not choose not
to participate OSHA by a legal culture
of serving problem with neighbors we
heard yesterday professor from Yale
asking what China has previous periods
of surveyed slam boundary issues and
things quite clear China have solve
amount of 14 countries where journalists
have this portlandor has soft off land
boundary issues and certainly a bulk of
Chongqing is also one of the very good
example the china stitch has managed to
solve the issues on a bilateral basis
and the third reason is about
electricians impact on confidence
building that we see from 2013 we don't
I don't want to link all this post
arbitrations development with as a
direct course for us from the
arbitration case but what we see in
after 2013 about the land reclamation
activities above this petrol and bought
all these new shape our lives I think it
all have an impact on the confidence
building because ed another day as a
professor are links that yesterday no
matter what composition that you are
going to make karma with it's up to the
country up to China and the Philippine
to come together again to negotiate how
to solve the issues the real issue is
between them this one just show you if
their interest in the very technical
issues of our jurisdiction and Mauritius
is simply given idea that the islands
regime our submission 346 answer has
been successfully enter into the me
rephrase and also our law enforcement
environment and their tribunal ruled
that they have jurisdictions but on the
issue of legality of Chinese door right
and also the action of China as
Philippines came easy incognito shelf
and date because the tribunal said they
won't be able to
decide what I have jurisdiction without
listening to the marriage so this all
other issue they were probably looking
to hear the result in the coming weeks
so I just want to make a little point
here I'm not very surprised that the
island regime submission has passed
through the third hole of jurisdiction
because there's no difference between
China and the Philippines those little
feature is China occupy right now or
anti-chinese can choose very small I'd
only China will use it to claim easy so
there is no fundamental difference
between the two countries and I just
want to show you because everyone is
talking about what where the internals
community we are if China does not
enforce the decision or the world so
we're not there yet but just want to
give you an idea if I try to look at a
lot of these cases in terms of
non-compliance on stay with internal
situation and also phone judicial
decision we see a lot of case a boundary
issue between Bolivia and Peru and going
to angrily raining oil company case and
caves concerning rite of passage over
India territory and all this case
actually we have I found there's a
common pattern which I summarized away
in the increasing number of cases a
party refused either to appear or to
participate in a stage of proceeding I
mean in a stage of either of the
jurisdiction and me rephrase and the
unwilling participants will nicely was
less likely than others to accept the
court's judgment and the dispute
especially dispute involving the land
boundaries and the history of conflict
receive the lowest level compliance let
me give you what to ism 11 is technical
issue is our next seven uncross does not
incorporate arbitration ward on into
domestic law so the job tub uncrossed
decide not to incorporate arbitration
Awards when they're under and a seven
into the master law of the state so why
providing an arbitration decision and
binding on state
Pradas but I nice ever lived
implementation and enforcement of the
decision to the political body of state
party for example in the uk's case the
case of UK virtuous required domestic
legislation in order to incorporate into
the domestic law countries like us
following an intermedia approach that
can see the word a treaty contains
mandatory language if it does not and it
becomes the master law and for oregon
just like kingdom northland incorporate
many treaties concluded by a security
branch into the master law and there was
2 k's 2 s2 hips a minute okay so there
are 2 k's and one is 1996 nicaragua
columbia case and when the US
participate in the phrase of gestation
but i decided to pull out whether the
ICJ decided that decided that it has
jurisdiction there was also another case
between Nicaragua Columbia so there's no
territory maritime the limitation bought
by Nicaragua against Colombia so when I
sitio de colombia has 70 / 7 dispute
islands and was in Caribbean but grant
and Nicaragua control a large amount of
surrounding waters so in dengar decided
to back out from that tricky part of our
cities so this is my last slice I think
this one will show you what is the
existing approaches for the region in
terms of merging the disp you to have
negotiation we have droid development
regional approach and certain we have
also just Putin so it's the right time
for off you consider how to resolve the
issue between a Clement States take up
upon again about the article 123 to
foster regional cooperation and then
leave the difficult issues outside and
they're making use of existing Maryland
cooperation fund and shortly between the
clement states and use these days as i
said yesterday there's a lot of more
common interest than differences that
the country should look
so we start over for him representation
thank you